did you know that for 20 years there was
a super secret sperm bank for the
world's smartest and most successful
people the idea started in 1980 when
multi-millionaire Robert K Graham
decided to start the repository for
germinal Choice the sperm bank only
allowed men with extraordinary
capabilities to donate sperm including
Nobel laureates Olympic athletes and men
with incredibly high IQ so why exactly
did Graham do this he wanted to improve
the human gene pool and he wanted to
create smarter healthier humans while
the sperm bank survived for about 20
years it was quite controversial and it
was shut down eventually in 1999 almost
two years after Graham died with all the
recent advancements in DNA and Gene
science I wouldn't be surprised if
someone tries it again